the YouTube purge it's something that a
lot of people have been talking about a
lot of rumors circulating there's a lot
of information out there some of it true
some of it I'm true gosh I wish I were
aging into a silver fox but instead I
just looked like a hobo getting the gray
here in my beard I apologize no Anderson
Cooper situation for me out I'm no
Gregory Peck this is a tough subject to
to to get into because there's a lot
that we don't know and I can't get into
all of the details that we believe to be
true but haven't necessarily verified
because I don't want to mislead you with
wrong information I don't want to scare
you with false information and I don't
want to give you false confidence with
wrong information so let me explain to
you what it is that that we do know okay
that we don't know and what
precautionary measures we are taking to
protect and inform our Channel and more
importantly the conservative community
on YouTube at large or really the
YouTube community at large because as we
saw from the recent controversy it
didn't it wasn't relegated to only the
conservative community okay
the YouTube purge is happening let me
say that this is something a lot of
people have talked about for a while
December 10th December 11th some new
policies coming down the pike a lot of
people have been concerned ourselves
included it is happening what we do know
the severity of it is I believe more
significant than most people have been
led to believe I believe that many of
you will be affected by it okay we do
know that this YouTube purge this new
policy new Community Guidelines no
YouTube's been talking about these new
anti-harassment these new guidelines for
several months now specific specifically
YouTube width sorry YouTube CEO Susan
Wojcicki
did mention that these will be occurring
in response to the controversy that was
generated by this channel over the
summer and certainly not sorry for the
content that we've created and that
you've come to enjoy I don't apologize
for that but obviously
my heart goes out to if there are any
future conservatives or future
independent voices who are affected
because some people got their feelings
hurt so we do know that this is why the
policies have been created we do know
that you will only know the full extent
of the policies once they are made
public Susan would just keep put this
out in an email I believe two weeks ago
I think I have this in my computer here
yes you will only find out all the
details after the policy is in effect so
kind of like we need to sign the bill to
know what's in the bill you know if you
like your doctor you can keep your
doctor that whole business um we don't
know exactly what the new policies are
or how they will be enforced and like I
said as more information is revealed to
me I'm gonna try and keep you guys in
the loop as best as possible by January
you guys will have the whole story I'll
tell you that right now I I want to be
prudent and I want to be wise in
whatever I deliver to you because this
is a big deal this is a big deal and
it'll affect a lot of you don't
certainly affect our channel I don't
know how long we're going to be here
I've talked about this and that's why I
do want to thank you guys so much
everyone who's joined in my club and
supported us I really do appreciate it
there's no way we could have survived
any of this or survived what is coming
down the pike without you guys joining
it Mudd Club there was no video
yesterday because we were kind of in a
tailspin trying to deal with some of the
new information regarding the YouTube
perch and we were taping and changed my
mind but there was a full show that went
up at Mudd Club there is a full show
today that goes up a lot of credit um so
smoke that you guys don't get on YouTube
there's a lot more content there
the biggest concern to me and I'm not
entirely sure about this but I'm pretty
confident is that the new policy which
we will only know once it is in effect
could apply retroactively Li now what
does that mean and I can't say this with
a hundred percent certainty when I get
more answers I'll let you know what that
means is that you could have uploaded a
video in 2012 2013 2014
guidelines at all and by the way there's
a big difference between being in
violation of community guidelines or the
rules or being advertiser friendly and
that's another thing that I can't verify
but we suspect with this policy they've
tried to keep those two things separate
we didn't violate any guidelines but
it's not advertising advertiser friendly
I believe that the two are going to be
more interchangeable as YouTube moves
forward can't say for sure but that is
what I believe as far as I understand it
these may apply retroactively lis so you
could have uploaded content that's fine
that was not in violation been in
compliance 2013 2014 2015 and now after
the new policies are in effect if those
videos which were in compliance when
they were originally created and
uploaded violate the new policy or
guidelines it could put your whole
channel in jeopardy which is a really
scary thing because we don't necessarily
know what these policies are that could
mean that you have videos that you've
been doing for a long time you could
have a series that you've been doing for
a long time without having a problem and
now all of a sudden it's retroactive Lee
a violation of guidelines and each one
could count as a striking a channel
could be removed not saying that's
exactly what will happen but my
understanding based on the information
which I do believe is correct it seems
that that's a distinct possibility
that's really worrisome
so precautions that we've taken rather
than risk the whole channel here being
removed in silence based on some policy
that we don't understand yet we have as
we we done after the converse in this
summer selected some older videos from
the channel and make them private and
made them available exclusively at mug
Club line of credit comm slash Month
Club as a precautionary measure because
the number one priority right now is to
make sure that our channel is still here
and that we can communicate with you as
more information is coming out and of
course please do if you haven't joined
the mug club yet we obviously appreciate
the support and would encourage you to
join me because it's the one place where
you know we can never we will never lose
touch with you so let me be clear about
something this is not finite I am
removing these videos right now
under protest in response to YouTube's
choice
- apparently keep moving the goal posts
and continue their continuation to
narrow content that can go on its
platform rather than err on the side of
openness they are choosing a different
path and they will continue to do so
until they hear from you so in the
meantime our our goal is to keep as much
content as accessible as possible find
out the rules and listen find out what
the rules are and learn to play by them
or you know what if we don't like the
rules then don't then we won't and we'll
take our ball and go home and go to mug
club that's always been an option that's
why we created it we don't know what the
rules are yet so what does that mean for
you I would encourage you all to right
now place a premium on making sure that
you are protecting yourselves and that
you are still open for business and
available to the public so that people
can reach you because it's a scary thing
if a bunch of you I have no idea but if
a bunch of you have that valve
shut off overnight it'll be really hard
for the audience that you've built up
and the people who come to know and
depend on your content to be able to
stay in touch with you that's an
important thing that's an important
thing so um what other advice where I
give to you guys well listen we're gonna
give you more sorry I know I'm just kind
of talking about this right now we've
removed I think 12 videos you can run a
search they'll be available at mug club
so you can go see what they are this
isn't necessarily permanent it's a
precautionary measure I will say this
for everyone else out there as more
information unfolds we'll try and keep
you posted come January there'll be a
lot more information what can you do
right now a couple of things first off
we are trying to aggregate as much
information as possible so if anyone
knows anything out there if you have a
more clear understanding of the policies
or if you have an inside inside skinny
and inside lane see comment below send
your emails two tips at ladder with
credit calm right now we want to
aggregate as much information as
possible verify the authenticity and
then disseminate it as effectively as
possible to everyone out here so
any information that you have that think
that you think could be helpful comment
tweet me and do send private messages if
you're concerned for the safety of your
content or your channel for everyone
else out there gird your loins keep your
head on a swivel be smart and fill your
hands you son of a [ __ ] because
depending on what comes down depending
on what we see coming over that
mountainside it may be the hill you die
on it may be the hell we die on we don't
know but in the words of Andrew
Breitbart there's always a possibility
war